빌사남의 간다는 세계적인 도시 그리고
제가 좋아하는 마천루들이 모여 있는
뉴욕 맨하튼에 왔습니다
[음악]
뉴욕에 지금 오피스 공실률이 매우
높아요네 매우 높은데 그거와 반해서
주거용은 공실률이 매우 낫습니다
그래서 제가 알고 있기로는 거의 한
1% 미만 아니면 진짜 3% 미만이
정도로 굉장히 낮다라고 좀 들었는데
제 현지에 지금 부동산업을 하고 있는
전문가를 모셨습니다 안녕하세요
안녕하세요 벌써 세 번째인데요 어
플래티넘 프로퍼티에서 한국 데스크를
맡고 있는 박입니다 반갑습니다 그
사실 오피스 실은 계속 높아요 지금
많은 사람들이 주거로 가지 않고
주거를 매입하지 않고 어 임대로 가기
때문에 또 맨하탄의 인구가 코로나
전보다 좀 늘었어요 아 늘었어요네
그러다 보니까 이런 복합적인 요소로
어 주거에 대한 수요가 높아졌고
임대에 대한 수요가 높아지다 보니
공실률은 낮고 임대료는 계속 올랐죠
그렇기 때문에 뉴욕 시가 지금 약간
어떤 이런 임대에 대한 공급을 늘리기
상당히 좀 혈안이 되어 있습니다
그리고 저는 또 궁금한 거 중에
하나가 그 오피스를 이제 주거용 으로
바꾼 그런 사례들을 좀 보고
싶어요네네 그래서 오늘 현장에 가서
좀 어떻게 변했는지 한번 같이 가서
보도록 하시죠네
[음악]
가보시죠
나탄의 오피스가 주거로 많이 커버링이
되고 있다라고 그런 걸 좀 보자고
하셔 갖고 나왔는데 지금 첫 번째
사례이 그 파이낸셜 디스트릭트에 25
워스트를 가서 한번 보실 거예요 아
그래서 이렇게 어 아주 커다란 규모에
약간 아이코닉한 컨버전을 예를 들
수가 있고요 그리고 가는 길에 보이는
이런 빌딩도 보세요 이게 공실이 엄청
높은데요 레지덴셜 컨버팅을 하는 거를
결정을 안 하고 자기네가 가지고 있는
인프라를 최대한 활용해서 아주 좋은
오피스로 다시 레노베이션 하고 있는
빌딩입니다 그까 지금 여러 가지를
보시면
아시겠지만네이 파셜 디스트릭트가
탈을 하고 있어요 코로나 이후에
발생한 뭐 재택 근무의 트렌드화
이걸로 발달이 된게 아니라 여기는 어
91 때부터 계속 변화되어 왔기
때문에 그런게 축적이 돼서 아마
맨하탄에서 가장 빠르게 오피스 지역이
약간 복합 지역으로 완성되는 그런
모습을 보여지는 지역이라고 저는
생각합니다
[음악]
네 지금 뒤에 있는 사례는 어떤
사례인가 저희가 25 워터 스트릿에
왔는데요 여기가 지금이 밑에 금융
지구에서 가장 커다란 규모 그
1300개의 유닛이 임대용 주거
상품으로 전환되고 있는 빌딩이 근데
기존에 22개의 빌딩을 위에 10개층
더 얹어서 우리 상구를 보시면 약간
오래된 오피스처럼 창도 되게 리밋
있고 어 되게 좀 답답한 구조인데
주고 변환이 되면서 이렇게 밑에 창도
넓어지고 위에 새로 개 충도 올리고
그런 부분으로 이제 가장 금융 지구
안에서 이루어지고 있는 16개의 빌딩
중에 규모가 가장 큰 곳으로 보시면
될 거 같고요 일 때부터 이미 오피스
공실이 높아서 약간 되게 좀 어려움을
겪었던 지역이기 때문에 16개의
빌딩들이 주거로 모두 전환이 되면 약
7천 실 가까운 주거가 새로 생기고요
한 유닛에 두 명씩만 거주한다고 해도
한 15,000명 정도의 인구가 새로
유입이 되는 거죠 빌딩들의 공사뿐만
아니라 주거 유닛이 들어가다 보니까
인프라 그리고 도로 여러 시설들을 다
지금 거주민이 거주할 수 있는 수준의
시설들로 만들기 위해서 여기가 완전히
공사 판이에요 한국에서 이쪽 지역을
보시고자 오는 분들이 아 여기다
투자를 해도 되나 여기 임대료가
이렇게 낮고 공실률이 다른 대입에서
좀 높고 주거를 매입했을 때 가격이
낮은데 여기는 그냥 이렇게 되는 곳이
아닌가라고 말씀들 하시지만 제가
현지에서 봤을 때는 금융 중심지라는
아이콘 닉 하죠 유입되는 주거 시설들
그리고 문화 시설들 앞으로 보시게 될
레저 시설들 그리고 교통 인프라가
너무 좋기 때문에 대표님도 한 3
4년 후에 오시면 아 여기가 이렇게
됐나요라고 하실 수 있을 정도로
투자로 봤을 때도 가능성도 좋고
기에도 앞으로 좀더 훨씬 더 좋아지는
지역으로 보여집니다 저도 여기 봤을
때 일단은 패리가 너무 잘돼는 거
같아 진짜 어디든 다 이제 갈 수
있게 좀 있는 거 같고 어떻게 보면
좀 빨리 오피스에서 이제 주거용으로
좀 빨리 바꾸고 있는 지역이긴 한데
바꾸고 나면 좀 어떻게 변할지 그
부분도 좀 지켜보면 좋을 거
같습니다네 종종 오셔서 한번 보시죠
알겠습니다
[음악]
여기가 이제 우리 그 경제 방송에
상상 보면 나오는 뉴욕 스닥죠 권
거에서 그죠 그래서 뭐 IPO
하거나네 뭐 이렇게 땡땡땡 중 그죠
팡도 여기서 했잖아요네 쿠팡도 여기서
하고 그래서 어떤 특정 회사가 아오를
하면 여기에 그 대형 현수막이 걸려요
저 위에 아 저기다 걸어줘네 저기다
걸어줘요 나중에 뭐 bsn이 나스닥에
상장을 하면 bsn
진짜요
[음악]
겠죠 저희가 아까 그 25 월
스트릿에서 쭉 한 5분 정도 걸어
왔잖아요이 걸어와서 보이는 곳이
여기가 이제 뉴욕 증권 고예요 그니까
많은 분들이 금융 지구가 그 완전히
주거지로 탈바꿈 하는 것이냐라고
질문을 하시는데 사실은 이런 증권 와
같이 200년 이상 역사가 된 곳이
이제 이전할 가능성도 없거든요 뭐
아까 말씀하신 것처럼 쿠팡도 여기서
IPO 했고요 그리고 여기서 두
블락만 더 내려가면 페더럴 리저브가
가지고 있는 뉴욕 그 본 점이 있어요
옛날에 영화에도 여러 번 나온게 이제
뭐 그 밑에 금고에 금이 뭐 몇 몇백
톤이 있다 뭐 이런 이런 아주 커다란
은행도 있고 그래서 여기가 금융의
아이콘적인 부분 기능은 그대로 또
가져갈 것으로 보이거든요 아 예 에
있는 6 월스트 같은 경우에도 여기서
이제 한 1분 거리죠 자기네가 아주
커다란 오피스 빌딩을 주거로 만들 수
있 있을 만한 빌딩을 가지고 있음에도
불구하고 그들은
센터를 가서 보시면 거기에 뮤지엄도
있고 아트 센터도 있고 그래서 한
도보로 10분 거리 안에 정말 많은
여러 가지의 기능을 가지고 있는
시설들이 있어서 그런 복합적인
지역으로 변하고 있다고 보시면 될 거
같아요 그니까 어떻게 보면 금융도
연결돼 있고 그다음에 약간 문화
시설도 연결돼 있고 그다음에 주거도
같이 연결되 있고 그다음에 오피스도
같이 연 그니까 여기가 금융으로
집중되 있던 90년대에는 거주민으로
신고된 분들이 불과 15,000
명이었어요 근데 지금 다섯 배가 더
늘어서 7만 명이 넘는 분들이
계시고요 지금 공급되고 있는 주거
시설들이 아까 제가 말씀드린게
7,000 유닛 이상 된다고
말씀드렸잖아요 제 개인적으로는 계속
어 여러분들 만나면 말씀드리지만 가장
변화가 맨에서 빨 빨리 이루어지고
있고 거의 정점에 와 있다 한국으로
비유하자면 좀 그 헬리오시티가 한
만세대 정도 되거 그니까 거의 그
정도 급이 들어오는 거니까 진짜
어마어마한
[음악]
거죠 뉴욕
증권거래소에서네 불가 한 블락
걸어왔는데 여기가 저 뒤에 보이시는
가장 높은 빌딩이 이제 60 월스트릿
이거든요 근데 여기는 이렇게 좋은
인프라를 가지고 있고 주거로 변환해도
이런 뷰라는 뭐 규모라는 이게 좋은데
여기는 오피스를 더 업그레이드해서
프라임 프라임 오피스로 변환하기를
했어요
그래서 지금 결정이고 뉴욕 타임에도
되게 대대적으로 기사가 나오고
했거든요 여기가 이제 2번 3번
트레인이 다니는 곳이잖아요 근데이
파이낸셜 디스트릭트가 맨하탄 섬에서
요렇게 좁아지나요
남쪽으로 그러면서이 전철이나 이런
메트로이드이 그 맨하탄의 곳곳으로 갈
수 있는 전철이 다 한 곳에 한 블락
안에 다 모여 있어요 그렇나 그러다
보니까 나가기도 좋고 들어오기도 좋고
그런 곳으로 보시면 될 것 같아요
여기서 또 빠질 수 없는게 어 월추
센터 쪽인데요 그쪽으로 한번
[음악]
가보실까요 지금 뒤에 있는이 터가 그
무너진 쌍둥이 빌딩이서 있던 자리예요
그러다 보니까 이제 이런 것들을 좀
기 위해서 관광객들이 와서 이런들도
보고 미국 분들은 그렇잖아요 그런 큰
사건들이 일어나면 그 자리를 보존해서
그거에 대한 기억을 잊지 말자이 지역
안에 월추 센터라는 이름을 가지고
있는 빌딩이 일곱 개가 있어요 네네
그래서 각각의 월추 센터들이 있고
거기에서 이제 업무 시설뿐만 아니라
그 아트 센터도 있어요 그니까 911
이후에 여기가 완전히 와 아웃 된
다음에 그 이 지역을 대표하는
거주민들이 지역에서 부동산을 소유하고
있는 소유자들 그리고 뉴욕시가 금융
지구에 대한 가지고 있는 가치 이런
것들이 모두 어울러져서 여기를 어떻게
의미 있고 더 활성화되고 더 좋게
개발할 수 있는지에 대한 여러 공부를
했겠죠 그런 문화와 업무와 이런 쇼핑
이런 것들을 한번에 좀 즐길 수도
있고 많은 사람들이 찾아와서 이렇게
둘러볼 수 있게끔
해놨고 때 때문에 사실 아까 뉴욕 스
익스체인지에 그런 관 관광객들이 와서
소녀상도 보고 뭐 밑에 황소도 보고
하지만 또 우리처럼 이렇게 걸어와서
이런 것도 보게 되거든요 그니까 진짜
거리상 너무 가까운 거 같아요네
그렇게 멀지 않죠 우리나라도 사실
이런 일들이 좀 있었잖아요 예를
들어서 뭐 삼풍 백화점도 있었고 그
뭐 성소 대교도 그고 이제 저 상품가
거기에 좀 뭐 비석이나 뭐 좀 그런
거라 진짜 최소한 그 정도라도 좀
설치했으면 좋았을 것 같은데 거기다
이제 주상복합 아파트가 올라가 가지고
그죠 여기처럼 이렇게 금싸라기 땅에
이렇게 큰 털을 비워서 또가 보셨지만
밑에 뮤지엄도 아주 크게 졌잖아요
너무 잘해 그런 어떤 아픈 기억을
잊지 않게끔 이렇게 해 놓는 거는 참
배울 점인 거 같습니다 아
[음악]
맞습니다 여기 이제 브룩필드
플레이스라고 오피스 빌딩인데 저
뒤쪽이 이제 배터리 파크 시티라고
해서 약간 인공 구조물 위에 건물들을
져서 주거가 또 한참 있어요 수변
공원과 함께 이쪽 동네에 약간 한적한
주거 주거형 지역으로 되어 있어요
그래서 거기가 개발된지가 벌써 한
30년이 넘었는데 처음에 개발됐을 때
텍스 베이트먼 그래서 20년 정도
세금 면제가 되기도 했고 예 그런
[음악]
곳입니다 그래서 아까 우리가
오피스에서 이야기했던 맨하트 난에서
어 1% 공실률을 가지고 있는 동네가
있다라고 말씀을 드렸었지요 그 지역
같은 경우에는 사실은 여기보다는 로얼
이스트 뭐 이스트 빌리지와 차이나
타운과 이런 것들이 중첩돼 있는
곳인데 왜 1% 있냐면 거기가 임대
가 가장 낮은 지역이라서요 아
그렇구나 그러니까 통계치가 2400불
월 2400불 미만의 임대료를 내고
있는 유닛이 가장 많이 밀집한 지역이
센트럴 파크 밑으로는 이스트 빌리지
그쪽 이거든요로 이스트 예예 그러니까
그쪽이 지금 어 가장 좀 이렇게
맨하탄 안에서도 가장 임대료가 좀
저렴하고 또 수입이 좀 낮은 분들이
많이 몰려가다 보니까 그쪽에 이제
공실률이 한없이 낮아지고 이제 찾아볼
수가 없는 거죠 파이낸셜 디스트릭트
는 공급도 많고 어 임대료도 거기보다
좀 비싸고 하니까 지금은 약간 그런
부분에서는 공실률이 다른 지역보다
조금 높기는 하죠 근데 2024년
현재 기준으로 맨하탄의 중간 임대료가
약 4500불 정도 해요 임대료가
올라가는 이유 중에
하나가이 아직도 높게 유지하고 있는
이자율 때문에 그 사고자 하는 분들이
임대료가 이자율이 너무 높다 보니까
상상을 못하는 거예요 이제 곧
패드에서 이번에 그 이자율
추지만네 이게
낮아지면서이 기존의 잠재 바이어들이
시장
유입되면서이 가격에 대한 변화가
임대료와 키를 맞출 거라고 저는 저는
100% 확신합니다 아 그렇구나
100% 없겠지만
[음악]
여기는 그 포트인 여기 폴트가 그
월스트릿 상징하는 지역이에요 이제
한참 옛날에 물동량이 많았을 때
여기에 그런 어떤 숙박 시설 상가
주거 시설이 밀집돼 있던 곳인데 특정
지역인요 시포트 지역만 역사 지구로
보존을 하고 있어서 높은 빌딩이 못
올라가요 그래서 이렇게 보시면 다른
곳들은 다 이렇게 하이 라이즈로
올라갔지만 저 지역만 좀 이렇게 낮은
빌드 이으로 구성되어 있는 거로 보실
수 있으시고요 뭐 투베드룸 있데 뭐
안에가 횡 풀려져 있지만 뭐 시드라
같은 걸로 그냥 이렇게 칸막이만
세우는 곳이 뭐 투 베드룸이 여기는
한 100만 불이면 접근 가능해요
100만 그래서 이런 지역에 맨하탄에
내가 좀 어 좀요 정도 가격에 거주를
하고 싶다 하고 투자를 하고 싶다라고
하면이 지역도 저는 나쁘게 보지는
않아요 그니까 여기가 금융 이 이번에
코로나 전에네 금융 위기도 겪었죠
그리고 그전에 허리케인 샌드라네
여기에 약간 커다란 폭풍 태풍이 와서
여기가 홍수를 한번 받았어요 네네 그
이후로 이제 맨하탄에서 약간 여기를
더 많은 인프라를 구축해서 홍수 방지
시스템을 만들어서 그 율은 홍수가
없었는데 그때 한번 좀
다쳤었는데
다쳤었는데 다시 올라오고
이 융 지구가
재개되면서 혜택을 받을 지역 중에
하나로 저는 이쪽을 좀 보거든요 전
개인적으로 이쪽 로프트를 뭐 좀 낮은
가격에 매입을 해서 임대를 오래
장기간 하다 보면 가치가 많이 오를
곳으로 저는 판단을 하고 있어요
그리고이 수변을 통해서 아까
얘기하셨던 그 리들이 많은데 페리를
타고 브루클린으로 넘어갈 수도 있고
나탄의 미드타운 나탄의 업타운 저지
트 아일랜드 이런 접근성도 매우
좋아서 또 뒤에 보이시는 여기 세틴이
그런 공연 장소로 상당히 이용이 많이
되고 있고요 저 윌리엄스 버그에서
사업을 하시거나 장사를 하시는 저희
지인분들이 아침에 페리를 타고
팀빌딩이 와서 아침 먹고 돌아가는 예
그런 케이스들도 많이
[음악]
있습니다 뉴욕에 이제 오피스 시장이랑
주거 시장에 대해서 좀 알아봤는데
제가 다음 편은 이제 뉴욕 현지에서
장사하고 계시는 fmb 사장님을 좀
인터뷰를 할 예정이거든요 그래서
저희가 혹시 좀 추가적으로 알아야 될
부분이나 이런게 있을까요네 요새 정말
그 한국에서 많이들 문을 두드리고
계세요네 그래서 저희가 현지에 대한
내용도 많이 설명을 드리고 하는데
정말 뭐 이렇게 관심이 있으시고
이쪽을 진출하시는 분들은 주거와
마찬가지인 거 같아요 오셔서 좀
다녀보시고 근데 처음에는 다 한 번에
결정을 못 하세요 오셔서 보시고 좀
수화도 시키시고 그래서 추가로
다니시면서 뭐 더 필요하신 상황이
있으시면 또 언제든지 연락 주십시오
예 추가적으로 또 궁금해 하시거나
아니면 이제 좀 진출하고 싶어하시는
분들도 계실 거 같거든요 그런 분들이
계시면은 저 박진우 사장님한테 연락
주시면 좋을 것 같습니다 그래서 오늘
영상은 여기까지 하고요 여러분들
빌딩은 사나네 렇습니다네
to find I don't
really try
[음악]
too we green or
yellow we or SH me
we about to we